earlier this month Airlines for America
trade group representing the major US
airlines as a federal government for 50
billion dollars in assistance to protect
and preserve the 750,000 jobs of
hard-working men and women who are
directly employed by US airlines this
set up a heated showdown there's the
industry which says it's in desperate
need of financial help and then there
are elected officials and activists who
say the airlines would not be in this
position if they did not spend so much
of their money on stock buybacks which a
lot of people see as the companies
lining the pockets of shareholders over
all else buybacks are often used as a
way to boost a company's stock price the
repurchase a shrink shares outstanding
which increases the value of the
remaining units they're frequently
viewed as a signal from management that
the stock is attractively priced so
we're going to take a look at the
airline's as own data to help explain
why people are so mad about this bailout
let's start with American Airlines it's
the biggest airline in the US and
reported having the most a hundred
thirty four thousand employees in 2019
let's take a moment here to watch the
amount American paid in salary wages and
benefits grow over the last 10 years now
it dips alone in 2013 but let's not
focus on that instead take a look at the
end point here in 2019 American reported
paying all of its employees a grand
total of twelve point six billion
dollars now let's add another line this
is the amount Americans spent on a share
buyback program which just means money
used to buy back its own stock it's a
move that financially engineer share
price gains which enriches shareholders
this didn't start happening until 2014
when the company spent just over 1
billion dollars on its stock its buyback
program shot up for the next couple of
years
before coming back down and staying
around the 1 billion dollar mark so
we've got a billion here almost 4
billion here 4.5 billion here and this
and this carry the 1 and if you add it
all up American has spent twelve point
nine billion dollars over the last six
years on its own stock people are mad
because twelve point six billion is what
it cost to pay the employees salaries
for an entire year and he would add up
everything on this buyback line it
surpasses that amount
and while stock buybacks are fairly
common there are some companies that do
have large emergency funds Apple a
company that was on the brink of
insolvency in the 90s is famous for
having a ton of cash on hand as of
January the company had more than 200
billion dollars in the bank call it a
rainy day fund call it a possible
Netflix acquisition the company has
built up one giant emergency fund this
might not be the case for the airline's
though that was American let's look at
Delta it's the second-biggest airline
and has about 91 thousand full-time
employees whose wages benefits and
everything else added up to just under
11 and a quarter billion dollars in 2019
now let's look at Delta's buyback
program didn't exist in the beginning of
the decade but in 2013 its 250 million
dollars in the annual report a year
later it's more than a billion to 2.6
all the way through to the end of 2019
over the past seven years
Delta spent just under 11 and a half
billion dollars buying back its own
stock that's almost the exact same
amount and spent paying all of its
employees salaries and benefits in 2019
let's do one final airline united on
March 20th the airline sent out a letter
saying it had already taken drastic
measures due to the downturn in travel
and would have to reduce payroll to
match a 60% cutting capacity if Congress
didn't act soon the airline reported 96
thousand employees at the end of 2019 if
we take a look at the last ten years of
its payroll we can see that in 2019
United paid out about 12 billion dollars
in salaries benefits and other related
items let's bring on uniting spy back
program this one began in 2014 at 252
million dollars the following year it's
more than a billion it crosses 2 billion
in 2016
comes back down a bit and in 2019 it's
about 1.6 billion dollars the total
amount spent on buybacks for that
five-year period is 8.8 billion dollars
that's about 75% of the entire amount
spent on wages and benefits for all of
2019 now of the 750,000 employees
Airlines for America says it represents
these three Airlines
for about three hundred twenty thousand
of them and collectively they would need
about thirty six billion dollars to pay
them for an entire year and collectively
over the last seven years they've spent
about thirty three point three billion
buying back their own stock the stimulus
bill has about 60 billion dollars set
aside for the airlines to be able to pay
their debts pay their employees and
basically keep the lights on but the
buyback numbers are what really
dominated the talks of any help for the
airlines so people are saying any
airline that is helped by federal funds
aka taxpayer money should have various
conditions attached like not being able
to buy back stock for a certain period
of time and the no buybacks became a
major point of contention and any talk
of federal help many airlines have spent
the last decade doing things to increase
profits at the cost of passenger comfort
like decreasing legroom to add more
seats and increasing checked bag fees
those increased profits were in part
used to buy back stock
and now the airlines are asking those
same passengers with less legroom and
$50 check bag fees to keep them afloat
the no buybacks demand worked the loans
and grants the stimulus bill has for the
airlines does have caveats that it can't
be used for buyback programs and the
bill requires any company receiving
assistance to freeze anyone's pay who is
receiving more than four hundred twenty
five thousand dollars a year meaning no
large increases for executives like CEOs
we reached out to the airlines for
comment American Airlines told us it had
invested twenty billion dollars in wages
and benefits while returning thirteen
and a half billion dollars to owners and
stakeholders the airline also said these
are extraordinary circumstances travel
restrictions and the downturn in demand
for commercial and transportation has
been Swift and dramatic Delta told us it
invested billions of dollars back in our
business improve the customer experience
in the air and on the ground achieved an
investment grade balance sheet by paying
down debt and funding our pension with
the remainder returned to our
shareholders through buybacks and
dividends United said in a statement it
had the highest growth in profit sharing
for our workers last year all which far
exceeds our share repurchases and that
it had suspended its share repurchase
program last month
now the airlines might not have just put
this money in the bank if they didn't do
buybacks the money could have been used
for R&D machinery reinvestment buying
another company pretty much anything and
the downturn caused by the coronavirus
is not the airlines his fault but the
speed at which they were affected might
make any CEO start to put away a bigger
emergency fund just in case